welcome to the last video for this week
there are many great deep learning
programming frameworks one of them is
tensorflow I'm excited to the help you
start to learn to use tender flow what I
want to do in this video is show you the
basic structure of a tensor flow program
and then leave you to practice and learn
more details and practice on yourself in
this week's projects designs this week's
Pro exercise will take some time to do
so please be sure to leave some extra
time to do it as the motivating problem
let's say that you have some cost
function J that you want to minimize and
for this example I'm going to use this
highly simple cost function J of W
equals W squared minus 10 W plus 25 so
that's the cost function you might
notice that this function is actually W
minus 5 squared if you expand out this
quadratic together expression above and
so the value of W that minimizes this is
w equals 5 but let's say we didn't know
that and you just have this function
let's see how you can implement
something intensive low to minimize this
because a very similar structure a
program can be used to train your
network where you can have some
complicated cost function J of W B
depending on all the parameters of your
neural network and then similarly you be
able to use tensorflow to automatically
try to find values of W and B then
minimize this cost function but let's
start with the simpler example on the
left so I'm running Python in my jupiter
notebook and so start-up tender so you
import numpy as empty and is idiomatic
to use import into flow as TF next let
me define the parameter W so intent of
flow you're going to use TF dot variable
to define a parameter title equals T F
dot float
32 and then let's define the cost
function so remember the cost function
was w squared minus 10 W plus 25
so you just PF dot add some would have W
squared plus TF dot multiply so the
second term was minus 10 times W and
then I'm going to add that to 25 so let
me put another GF dot ad over there so
that defines the cost J that we had and
then I'm going to write train equals T f
dot train dot gradient descent optimizer
let's use a learning rate of 0.01 and
the goal is to minimize the cost and
finally the following few lines are
quite idiomatic in it equals P f dot
global variables initializer and then on
session equals T F dot the profession
from starter sensical session session
you got to run a lit to initialize a
global variables and then for tend to
filter you value the variable we're
going to use set start run W we haven't
done anything yet so with this line
above initialize W to zero and define a
cost function will define train to be
our learning algorithm which uses a
gradient descent optimizer to minimize
the cost function but we haven't
actually run the learning algorithm yet
so sessions are run we evaluate W and
then we print session run so if you run
that evaluate W to be equal to zero
because you haven't done anything yet
now let's do sessions are run on train
so what this will do is run one step of
gradient descent and then let's
evaluate the value of W after one step
of gradient descent and print that so we
do that after one step agreeing to send
W is now zero point one let's now run a
thousand iterations of gradient descent
so run train and let's then print
session that and run W so this is run a
thousand iterations of grande descent
and at the end W ends up being four
point nine nine nine nine remember we
said that we're minimizing W minus five
squared so the optimal value of W is
five and got very close to this so hope
this gives you a sense of the broad
structure of a tensor flow program and
as you do therefore we exercise and play
with more tensorflow close yourself some
of these functions that I'm using here
will become more familiar some things to
notice about this w is the parameter
we're trying to optimize so we're going
to declare that as a variable and notice
that all we had to do was define a cost
function using these add and multiply
and so on functions and tend to throws
automatically how to take derivatives
respect to the add and multiply as well
as other functions which is why you only
have to implement basically forward prop
and it can figure out how to do the back
problem of the gradient computation
because that's already built in to the
add and multiply as well as the squaring
functions by the way in case this
notation seems really ugly since the
flow actually has overloaded the
computation for the usual plus minus and
so on so you can also just write this
nicer format so it cost to comment that
out and if you run this and get the same
result
so once W is declared to be attentive so
variable these squaring multiplication
adding and subtraction operations are
over though this you don't need to use
this a griffon check
had above now there's just one more
feature of ten to fill that I want to
show you which is this example minimize
a fixed function of W one of the
function you want to minimize is a
function of your training set so
whatever you have some training data X
and when you train your neural network
the training data X can change so how do
you get training data into a 10-2 phone
program so I'm going to find key X which
is think of this as playing a role of a
training data or really the training
data with both x and y but we only get X
in this example so there's going to
define exterior placeholder and it's
going to be of type float 32 and let's
make those a three by one array and what
I'm going to do is whereas the cost here
has fixed coefficients in front of the V
terms in this quadratic use one times W
squared minus ten times W plus 25 we
could turn these numbers 1 minus 10 and
25 into data so what I'm going to do is
replace the cost with cost equals x 0 0
times W squared plus x10 times W plus x2
0 o times 1 so now X becomes sort of
like data that controls the coefficients
of this quadratic function and this
placeholder function tells tensorflow
that X is something that you provide the
values for the retailer so let's define
another arrays coefficient equals NP
dot array 1
- 10 and yes the last value is 25 so
that's going to be the data that we're
going to plug into X so finally we need
a way to get this a very coefficients
into the variable X and the syntax to do
that is doing the training step that the
value 4 will need to be provided for X
so I'm going to set here 6 equals x
that's through coefficients and I'm
going to change this in a copy and paste
and put that here as well all right
hopefully I didn't have any syntax
errors let's try to be running this and
we get the same results hopefully as
before and now if you want to change the
coefficients of this quadratic function
let's say you take this 10 and change it
to 20 minus 20 and let's change this to
100 so this is now the function X minus
10 squared and if I rerun this hopefully
I find that the value that minimizes X
minus 10 squared this w equals 10 let's
see cool great we got W very close to 10
after running a thousand iterations of
gradient descent so what you see more of
when you do the exercise is that a
placeholder in terms of flow is a
variable whose value you assign later
and this is a convenient way to get your
training data into the cost function and
the way you get your data into the cost
function is with this syntax on when
you're running a training iteration to
use the feet dip to set X to be equal to
the coefficients here and if you're
doing mini-batch gradient descent where
on each iteration you need to plug in a
different mini batch then on different
iterations you use the feet thick to
feed in different subsets of your
training set different meaning
into where your cost function is
expecting to see data so hopefully this
gives you a sense of what tens of so can
do and the thing that makes it so
powerful is all you need to do is
specify how to compute the cost function
and then it takes derivatives and it can
apply a gradient optimizer or an atom
optimizer or some other optimizer with
just you know pretty much one or two
lines of code so here's the code again
I've cleaned this up just a little bit
and in case some of these functions or
variables seem a little bit mysterious
to you still they will become more
familiar after you practice with it a
couple times by working through their
programming exercise just one last thing
I want to mention these three lines of
code are quite idiomatic in terms of
flow and what some program is will do is
use this alternative format which
basically does the same thing set
session to TF dot session to start the
session and use the session to run in it
and then use the session to evaluate CW
and in print of result but this with
construction is used in a number of tens
of flow programs as well it more or less
means the same thing as the thing on the
left but the words command in Python is
a little bit better and cleaning up in
cases an error on exception what we're
accusing this in a loop so you see this
in there from an exercise as well so
what is this code really doing let's
focus on this equation the heart of a
tentacle program is something to compute
a cost and then ten to flow
automatically figures out the
derivatives and how to minimize that
cost so what this equation or what does
some line of code is doing is its
allowing tender flow to construct a
computation graph and a computation
drought does the following
it takes X 0 0 it takes W and then I
guess W gets squared and then X 0 0 gets
multiplied with W squared
you have X zero zero times W squared and
so on right and eventually you know this
gets built up to compute this xw x zero
zero times W squared plus x10 times W
plus and so on and so eventually you get
your the cost function right now against
the last term to be added would be a x2
0 where it gets added to be the cost I
won't write the other form under the
cost and and the nice thing about center
flow is that by implementing maybe
forward propagation through this
computation graph the computed cost tens
of flow has already back built in all
the necessary backward functions so
remember how training a thief new
network has a set of forward functions
instead of backward functions and
programming frameworks Blake tensorflow
have already built in the necessary
backward functions which is why by using
the built-in functions to compute the
forward function it can automatically do
the backward functions as well to
implement back propagation through even
very complicated functions and compute
derivatives for you so that's why you
don't need to explicitly implement back
prop and this is one of the things that
make the proving framework
help you become really efficient if you
look at the terms of so documentation
I just don't point out that the
tentacled documentation uses a slightly
different notation then I did for
drawing the computation graph that uses
X 0 0 W and then rather than writing the
value like W squared the tension-filled
documentation tends to just write the
operations so this would be a square
operation and these two get combined in
a multiplication operation and so on and
then the final note I get there'd be a
addition operation when you add X to 0
to find a final value so for the
purposes of this clause I thought that
this notation for the compensation drop
would be easier for you to understand
but if you look at the tensorflow
documentation as we look at the
computation graphs in the documentation
you see this alternative convention
where the nodes are labeled with the
operations rather than with the value
but both of these representations you
represent basically the same computation
graph and a lot of things they can do
with just one line of code in
programming frameworks for example if
you don't want to use gradient descent
but instead you want to use the atom
optimizer by changing this line of code
you can very quickly swap it swap in a
better optimization algorithm so all the
modern deep learning program frameworks
support things like this and makes it
really easy for you to code up even
pretty complex neural networks so I hope
this was helpful for giving you a sense
of the typical structure of a tensor
field program to recap the material from
this week you saw how to systematically
organize the hyper parameter search
process we also talked about batch
normalization and how you can use that
to speed up training of your networks
and finally we talked about programming
frameworks so deep learning there are
many great program frameworks and we had
this last video focusing on tens of so
with that I hope you enjoyed this week's
pro exercise and that helps you gain
even more familiarity with these ideas